[Musique]
alors que la france est à l'arrêt depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois et qu'une
réouverture des lieux publics va devoir
d'être envisagées le gouvernement se
pose des questions sur les stratégies à
adopter pour ouvrir dans de bonnes
conditions
parmi celles envisagées le passeport
vaccinale c'est donner un passeport aux
personnes vaccinées qui leur permettrait
de vivre quasiment comme avant un
passeport qui dans un premier temps
permettrait à ses détenteurs de pouvoir
à nouveau voyager et qui pourrait aussi
s'étendre à d'autres accès comme les
restaurants les musées ou autres lieux
clos si certains de nos voisins
européens l'ont déjà adoptée comme le
danemark la suède ou encore israël
en france les avis sont tranchés d'à
côté ceux qui pensent que c'est la seule
solution pour pouvoir continuer à vivre
si vous êtes vacciné vous aurez accès à
un avion b c'est ce qui va se passer de
toute façon d'autres ceux qui pointent
du doigt la privation des libertés et
les risques de discrimination je n'y
suis pas favorable pour des raisons je
dirais d'abord scientifique et un peu
éthique quand même aussi à leur cinéma
voyages restaurants
faut-il mettre en place un passeport
vaccinale ce soir le dr robert sebbag et
l'avocat maître divisions se font face
merci à vous d'être là merci robert sexy
docteur d'être là et merci maître
fabrice di vizio d'être avec nous
également alors ici il y en a que deux
qui sont contre et beaucoup qui sont à
raymond il est content puisque trv
pourquoi tu es contre je suis content
parce que c'est les libertés pour moi ça
va faire de la discrimination ça veut
dire que celui qui veut pas qu'on lui
injecte un vaccin dans le bras par
exemple il a pensé
il me raconte maxime il veut pas y aller
dis moi je veux pas qu'on me vaccine
parce que je sais pas dans cinq ans si
ça va me faire quelque chose je sais pas
dans 10 ans enquêtes achevées être je ne
veux pas c'est à dire que lui ont valu
10 rebonds alors si tu veux pas puis de
cinéma puis de resto pub fait tout ça tu
de foot plus de trucs en plein air pur
théâtre c'est fini tu restes chez toi et
tu meurs sa sentence à ce que dirais tu
meurs tu auras des loyers à temps des
personnes va filmer deux paquets de
cigarettes par jour
je suis par exemple moi je fume pas
paraguay mais il va prendre des risques
pour sa santé dans sa nombre dans dix
ans dans 15 ans on n'a pas le choix il
peut mourir entre à l'argent mais cesser
une situation comme annoncé plus tôt
oui mais sauf évidemment que c'est très
intelligent sauf que c'est une situation
qui est exceptionnel dont il m'a arrêté
de toujours parler de du fait qu'on ne
sera pas libre avec ce passeport
vaccinale on n'a pas le choix il faut
déverrouiller le pays
il faut qu'on reprenne une activité il
faut qu'on puisse aller dans les
restaurants dans les terrains vagues
l'on sait c'est la seule solution
il le faudra les compagnies aériennes
certaines comme étiez à emirates sont en
train de le mettre en place ce sera la
seule solution alors j'attends bien sûr
notre avis bien sûr sur ces 8 on va voir
la vie du docteur et de mettre division
qui n'a pas l'air qui a l'air plutôt
d'accord avec raymond depuis tout à
l'heure d'écrire al-din par liddy allait
pas tout à fait d'accord
oui il faut pas juger vraiment partir du
cafouillage de maintenant on part du
principe que d'ici peu de temps tout le
monde pour être maxime et
il a pas vibrer il est l'or lui palais
ou par mail qu'ils veulent et nagoya
c'est là tout s'est passé si c'est un
choix
j'ai parlé au départ il ya même pays on
vous demandait le sport de vaccins
contre la fièvre jaune peut pas avoir le
bac ça m'as tu n'y vas pas ah bah si
mais moi j'étais très fier non mais on
m'a demandé ma que ça a commencé comme
ça quand on parle effectivement de droit
on va essayer d'être prêt si le
passeport effectivement vaccinale il
vient dans les pois fièvre jaune en
particulier c'est parce que pour accéder
au pays
il vous faut s car en vaccins
obligatoires
exactement vous ne pouvez pas accéder
sur le territoire du pays
si le vaccin n'est pas juste obliga m
division donc c'est pas un problème
effectivement de restaurant ou par
réaction c'est pas une discrimination
n'a rien à voir c'est un problème de
territoire italien l'a très bien démarré
l'émission depuis qu'il a après me l'a
dit une phrase économiques attendent
d'accéder pour aller au restaurant c'est
la même chose pour aller dans sa salle
rien à voir mais trop diminuée quelque
chose avec lequel on ne joue pas c'est
le prince et principes juridiques vous
pouvez pas si vous voulez faire de la
proximité permanente et comparer un
restaurant et un territoire national
pourquoi s assurer qu il ya un truc à
lui c'est de l'approximation permanent
il ya deux situations soit vous avez une
obligation vaccinale
soit vous avez une liberté vaccinale
mais entre les deux il n'y a rien non
mais il est dans l'approximation n'y a
rien soit l'état décide sous certaines
conditions alors de poser mes
obligations aa qui n'a le droit de le
faire il l'a fait pour certaines des
vaccins obligatoires en france soit ils
décident d'une liberté vaccinale mais
entre les deux il n'y a rien alors
j'aimerais avoir l'avis du docteur
robert se battent vous vous êtes pour ce
passeport atteint 1 c'est pas ça
s'exprime pas on pourrait en compte
d'abord la première chose je vais faire
de la sémantique c'est pas un passeport
vaccinale il faut parler des passeports
immunitaire un passeport immunitaire
parce que vous avez déjà eu en client
je vais y revenir après il vous avait
déjà en curieux l'infection qui ont des
anticorps qui sont pas vaccinés alors
ces gens quoi on va leur dire vous vous
avez des anticorps tant que bon après
vous avez des obligations comme vous
l'avez dit m deux situations
vous avez des pays vous n'êtes pas
responsables qui disent moi si vous
voulez rentrer chez moi moi j'ai réussi
à vacciner tout le monde vous êtes
vacciné vous n'êtes pas vacciné blanc
vous voyagez pas ça c'est une chose
après la deuxième chose on peut à la
rigueur discuter les restaurants les
cinémas si tout le monde est vaccinée ça
veut dire quoi c'est pas les gens des
ehpad qui ont été vaccinés c'est pas les
gens de plus de 75 ans qui vont aller
dans les restaurants dans les cinémas si
vous voulez ça veut dire que les jeunes
moi je suis jeune je re faible à moi
mais enfin les jeunes vont dire attendez
moi je ferai pas vacciner avant le mois
d'août peut-être le mois de septembre
eu égard à la vitesse de la vaccination
aujourd'hui donc moi j'ai pas le droit
d'aller au cinéma j'ai pas le droit de
leur les restos c'est ça il faut être
il faut être extrêmement prudent là
dessus deuxièmement il ya l'obligation
alors est ce qu'il ya une obligation
vaccinale en france non on le répète ça
veut dire que si vous n'avez il ya des
gens qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner
ça veut dire oui mais ça veut dire
docteur c'est à dire que si on en place
ce passeport vaccinale ça veut dire
qu'ils vont voir les gens qui veulent
pas faire vacciner ils vont voir tous
leurs amis tous leurs potes discord
famille peut-être qu'ils sont fait
vacciner aller au restaurant ya les
sorties sortir pour aller dans des
musées il peut y peuvent rien faire
filmez vous avez un autre argument
pardon c'est les faux assez si vous
installez ce genre de chose d'ailleurs
si on a vu des faux sur les tests pardon
et asus sur denses où vous allez donc il
faut être extrêmement prudent et alors
pour terminer assez sur moi je suis
contre le
sport vaccinale tels que vous l'appelez
d'accord a très bien donc il ya un prix
m au t2 problème quand on parle de
vaccins faire très attention la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme là on
attend un arrêt de la grande chambre
donc la formation la plus solennelle sur
l'obligation vaccinale est ce qu'il est
conforme à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme d'imposer une
obligation nationale
eh bien figurez-vous ça c'est important
c'est ben figurez vous que n'ont pas dit
non à la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme et liszt intéressant on pensait
à titre personnel les jurys tu pensais
que c'était réglé que c'est possible
eh ben la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme est en train de vous dire on
n'est pas sûr on s'est réunis en
formation solennel et on attend l'arrêt
qui devait intervenir ya déjà deux mois
qui est toujours pas intervenue donc
c'est qu'on se dit ben c'est pas comme
ça c'est intéressant ce que dit m m e
division bravo parce que je connais des
gens qui font des apprentis ne vous êtes
extrêmement précis brigitte vernay même
sur le sol français ça induit un aspect
qui est non conforme à la constitution
c'est une ségrégation sur le territoire
français et le conseil constitutionnel
rejette rsa forcément parce que vous
avez les gens qui ne peuvent pas se
faire vacciner aussi pourquoi on peut
revenir à votre avis mon avis est que je
suis absolument contre parce que ce
n'est pas conforme à la légalité
républicaine
on induit une inégalité entre les
journal bien ceux qui ne veulent pas et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas cyril il ya
plein de gens qui n'ont pas accès aux
vaccins en ce moment demande qui
n'auront pas accès avant d'être dévoilée
mercredi ce débat là aux mangas raymond
m e division robert ce match parce que
sinon c'est caca les programmes les
autres alors quelqu'un d'intéressant
souper l'interné comme louis d'alain
faut mettre en place un passeport
actional pour une raison simple c'est
que aujourd'hui on a fermé les
frontières il va bien falloir aborder
qu'on puisse voyager et je puisse
rentrer et sortir du pays et mais à un
moment donné surtout éradiquer la comida
même moment les réaliser la colline vous
posez ces questions pour les autres
épidémies ou jamais et ça te défoncer
adoré mais moi j'ai posé une question et
en dédiant retourne maladie ok des
maladies conditions mais j'attends des
missions disparu fréquemment son chat
longtemps vous fallait quelqu'un qui
soit en cas aujourd'hui
l'avenir monsieur s'est parlé on la met
à tomber monsieur s'est effectivement il
existe d'autres épidémies
ça vous a échappé non parce que à un
moment donné on a l'impression que là on
découvre l'épidémie a on découvre la
notion des piles et vous savez que
certains pays ou ebola vous savez que
certains pêcheurs ont la malaria
vous savez que certains pays ont des
débits beaucoup plus dangereux que la
copie puisque sa seule à avoir échappé
au bon sens là donc on va tous se calmer
cinq minutes le coach a beau être le
patron mais j'ai pas répondre à une
problématique dont tout cela est faux
départ vous raconter n'importe quoi le
postulat il faut des mois mais enfin si
vous aimez ça m'agace à un moment donné
sur le plan du droit vous viennent en
permanence me rappelais conneries sur
les frontières et machin arrêté
d'employer des tablettes des vidéos vous
n'aimez pas ça va quand même que là on
rigole d'un truc banal et on rigole d'un
truc qui s'appelle les droits de l'homme
ouais c'est avec elle des gens sont
morts quand même sega nous
mais pas trop docteur cyrille la
tuberculose maladie respiratoire
transmissibles et je peux vous assurer
que dans mon service envoie encore
beaucoup de tuberculose est ce qu on
demande aux gens vous avez été
tuberculeux en effet un test comme quoi
vous n'êtes pas tuberculeux ils peuvent
aller dans les restaurants
il ya un moment je voulais la notion de
risque crie elle existe alors pour
rassurer simplement pour rassurer
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui en s'excitant
là tous envie d'aller au restaurant
aussi un jour pour assurer on sait si
vous voulez que qui va y avoir une
immunité collective qui va se faire avec
la vaccination c'est que les gens
combien pourcentage de la population
soit 170 pour ça c'est un acquis mais on
sait que je suis si fière que ça
n'existait pas quoi là-bas je peux mais
à fond vous faire un point sur les 18
ans gym et affection ce que je veux dire
c'est que entre la vaccination les gens
qui ont été infectés vous avoir une
certaine immunité collective et ça va et
le site le virus va beaucoup moins
circuler et au bout d'un moment si vous
voulez parce qu'il y aura une immunité
gerald on va voir on a quatre hot
coronavirus qui tous les ans samedi des
rhumes
c'est pas très grave donc aujourd'hui on
a très très peur parce que c'est
effectivement cette maladie peut être
grave
on n'a pas encore tous les moyens vous
l'a dit on se dit fois passant vaccinale
pour visiter le restaurant cinéma rhj
mais mais je pense que il faut pas la
liberté ça existe aussi sur le risque il
existe aussi
on peut pas demander demain de demain on
va dire à des gens m'attendaient vous
vous êtes ceci vous êtes cela vous avez
vous avez des maladies de peau vous
allez toucher mes verres c'est sans fin
je vous assure c'est sans fin il faut
être extrêmement d'areva en quatre
sucreries le risque il existe on va
vivre le risque on vit avec le risque
d'attraper la tuberculose
on rit ça valorise avoir cédé des virus
respiratoire syncitial la grippe la
grippe vous demandez pas aux gens et
vous accédez contre la grippe
on sait que tout le monde n'est pas
vacciné et on sur la grippe les ailes et
c'est une maladie respiratoire donc
raison garder
il faut savoir raison garder
2 maintenant vous avez des étapes qui
obligeront effectivement quillan vous
dirai pas alors aujourd'hui s'ils
voulaient leur nuit jan
si vous n'avez pas la fièvre jaune vous
ne pourrez pas aller à cayenne tous les
deux vous êtes contre donc ce passeport
vaccinale j'aimerais avoir l'avis widow
dolphin en fait il ya quelques temps
quand macron a pris la parole il alors
du cmaq rôle président a pris la parole
il avait dit le vaccin ne sera pas
obligatoire et après quand on avait
regardé ce truc là dans les foyers ça
disait non mais tu imagines le jour où
tu veux prendre l'avion de toute façon
et vous nous faire un truc tu devrais
être vaccinés pour prendre l'avion
et ça on disait ça au futur est en fait
au final on se pose la question de
demain donc oui c'est pas obligatoire
mais ça va être obligatoire pour
retrouver nos libertés donc encore une
fois c'était de la rue fénelon du phrasé
notre division gare de métro division va
vous défoncer syrienne qui m'impose un
vaccin elle commet effectivement haut
débit ouais elle n'a pas le droit de
faire ça ils n'ont pas le droit non ils
n'ont pas le droit même si avec landry
savoir le coup alors ça pour le coup moi
d'y voir un truc comme ça ça marche pas
non non c'est impossible bien mais on
n'avait pas je veux dire très près on
peut pas on peut pas si vous voulez vous
imaginez le trophée mur non mais vous
imaginez qu'il ya un autre problème et
dr sebag effectivement passera passera
bien d'accord sur ce point ces points du
secret médical quand même un moment
donné j'ai pensé belle c'est quoi la
prochaine étape c'est je suis s'il ya un
hommage au sida je suis cancéreux on va
on va jusqu'où ça chez daiwa glissé
qu'elles payeraient médical caisse
casillas adan j'avais unical mais l'a
pas dit qu'ils étaient pour le ramener
chez elle comme tous ces sans limites
sans limite tout ça alors moi je suis
diabétique
le psy diabétiques je vais dans un
restaurant je vais demander des gâteaux
des tas de plats ultime lundi attendait
mais si vous êtes diabétique moi je vais
pas vous servir ça la liberté c'est
aussi ça bien sûr d'aller sur cette
diabétiques vous prenez votre risque
c'est ça vous prenez un certain niveau
de responsabilité voilà
m vous ne mettez pas en péril les autres
soirées s'est resserrée complémentaires
les autres mais vous les mettez en péril
avec la grille où l'émetteur d'ailleurs
été forclose pourquoi nous fait une
différence dans ces cas-là imposer un
pasteur vaccinale pour toutes les
épidémies 6ème journée du prix et
pourquoi madame arrêtez de vous adonner
excusez moi mais pourquoi vous faites
une différence et une focalisation sur
une épidémie pourquoi le coup vide
pourquoi pas tuberculose dirigeants
arrêtés le monde la salle a ri chanté le
monde ça a été le monde mais à
tuberculeux s'arrêter le monde
donc en fait on prend le problème par la
conséquence est pas par la cause oui
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné vous
avez effectivement un mouvement de
panique généralisée et vous dites que ça
augmente panique généralisée il conduit
il vient effectivement conduire à
l'action publique mais vous êtes dingues
génère pardonnez moi mais vous êtes
dingues à un moment donné je veux comme
pour appeler un truc en 1914
on m'a jamais parlé comme attendu
conseil d'état a décidé un truc
extrêmement intéressant il ya une
formule qui a traversé les siècles
depuis 1914
en france la liberté est la règle et la
police l'exception vous imaginez en 1914
on vivait une heure un peu sombre à 1914
et on peut dire que le monde aussi est
un peu dans la merde en 14 ans c'est à
dire la liberté est la règle la police
l'exception non mais je tenais vdev d'y
aller il va peut-être président emmanuel
macron nous a quand même dit plusieurs
fois qu'on était en guerre
moi je l'entend de plus enfin je
regardais en mer donc moi quand on me
dit on est en guerre mais on n'est pas
en du président qu'il faut l'écouter je
vous dirais lorsque j'entends les
médecins je me dis bon je vais écouter
les médecins maintenant le président a
parlé je vais [ __ ] les médecins si le
coup les médecins me disent ça y est le
vaccin il est sûre il est sûr c'est un
temps tu peux te faire vacciner on l'a
demandé à plusieurs médecins
ils sont de plus en plus tous d'accord
ensemble à nous dire le vaccin il est
sûr c'est que je me dis si on est en
guerre et qu'on a un vaccin qui est sûr
je change d'avis parce qu'avant j'étais
contre maintenant j'ai changé d'avis en
effet si ce n'est pas d'accord vous
confondez le je peux et je dois vous
faire vacciner famille maghreb je vais
me faire vacciner je veux accéder mais
si vous vouliez que bien que des notions
je le redis soit vous imposer un vaccin
et pourquoi pas vous pouvez l'imposer
certaines conditions le conseil conscio
neil a posé des conditions
pour imposer un vaccin ne s'est pas
totalement arbitraire soit vous décidez
une liberté vaccinale mais le président
de la république il a peut-être dit
qu'on est en guerre d'abord faudra qu'on
arrête avec ce mot ça m'énerve je n'ai
pas en juillet un langage et après on
vient utiliser les métaphores pour dire
regardez c'est grave mais mais on est en
mode et pang qinghua une chose est visé
il a utilisé plein de fois le mot gay
non mais il a utilisé plein de fois le
mot guerre effectivement on n'est
peut-être pas obligé de prendre les
métaphores au pied de la lettre et de
les utiliser comme des concepts alors si
elles n'en ont guère où sont les
généraux où sont les militaires mais
fabien sait quoi l'approché sera basée
la 4e journée s'adresse klaxon pour
autour de la table on n'a pas entendu
tout le monde et notamment bernard
montiel porte parole du gouvernement
vous dites oui oui bien sûr oui et
d'ailleurs madame bachelot puisque vous
me parlez du gouvernement elle est
opposée aux patients vaccinés
il faut le savoir dont vous voyez que on
peut avoir des amis quelque part elle
pas être d'accord tout le temps avec
l'âge je suis tout à fait contre elle
moi j'y crois beaucoup à ce passeport
parce que ce sera nécessaire forcément
bien sûr ça peut paraître comme une
atteinte aux libertés mais je crois que
c'est nécessaire de toute façon il
paraît je ne sais pas si jamais vous
faites vacciner
ce qui ne nous est pas arrivé encore à
nous on est encore très jeune avec isa
mais ça pas tardé il paraît qu'on
délivre tout de même un certificat de
vaccination
ces points sont là d'office qua non
existent déjà donc si vous voulez on est
oublié de remplir un certificat avec le
numéro du lot n'a etc poursuivre les
gens cette race est donc vous alors que
le mans s'est déjà amassée pas une carte
d'identité c'est rachida il a pas de
validité juridique si vous voulez
fermement la traçabilité qui est
extrêmement importante que vous êtes
vacciné
alors oui on a un petit sertic mais
trois divisions vous voulez fracassé
berlin
c'est à saab il faut que vous avez ça
vous arrêtiez avec les formules ouais je
peux comprendre que peut-être ça soye
atteinte aux libertés mais bien sûr que
si les atteintes aux libertés et vous tu
m'aimes confinement j'étais avec jean
paul stahl
la semaine dernière jean paul sartre
effectivement utilisé le confinement
peut être atteinte aux libertés bah non
c'est une atteinte aux libertés
c'est pas parce que ces atteintes aux
libertés que c'est pas nécessaire c'est
pas ça que je dis je dis qu'il faut
d'abord commencer par le commencement
et dire que oui une atteinte aux
libertés et que oui de nos libertés sont
possibles si elles sont justifiées par
des motifs de santé publique
ici c'est pas le cas et si vous vous
engagez je vous garantie un truc
mettez le toit ça pour le coup pendant
une spécialité en sciences politiques
mettez le doigt dans cet engrenage et
vous allez vous en mordre les doigts
à raison de 15 ans ou de 20 ans j'étais
sans quoi vous parlez que de l'atteinte
aux libertés mais si à un moment donné
moi j'oublie l'atteinte à la liberté
si à un moment donné ça nous permet de
pouvoir revenir dans des restaurants
voyager se révèlera sereinement aurait
ouvrir toute l'économie qui est en berne
en vain la france n'a jamais et enfin
l'europe et le monde le nom md aussi au
bord du précipice depuis six ans
pourquoi ces jeunes joueuses savent
regarder
regardez ya pas longtemps on rentrait
dans les restaurants ont donné son
numéro de téléphone eh ben c'est et on
était quoi qu'à contacter s'est passé
les bains ça te laissons ce que vous
dites pour les bons autre exemple est
parfait qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors
pas de déflation vous savez ce qui s'est
passé est ce que vous savez pourquoi
cette mesure était stupide
après de la liberté les gens vous savez
ce qui s'est passé les gens ont donné
des faux numéro
la raison plus qu'un élément là c'est
comme vous avez tort sur un point je
comprends parfaitement ce que vous dites
simplement vous avez tort sur un point
vous partez du principe que c'est
nécessaire qui le décide pourquoi ce
sera nécessaire et pas pourquoi
ou est ce qui est inscrit quelque part
que pour aller bouffer dans un resto je
dois effectivement je vous repose la
question de bon sens avant d'oser la
vidéo on nous avait dit la même chose
pour les masquer on nous avait dit mais
attention si vous mettez des masques
vous verrez l'épidémie s'arrêtera
finalement l'épidémie s'est pas arrêtée
et balsa vie si vous les mettez à
l'extérieur
l'épidémie s'arrêtera finalement s est
pas arrêté maintenant on dit si vous
êtes vacciné épidémie s'arrêtera elle si
elle s'arrête pas on fait quoi
c'est un postulat de départ
et si ça marche pas le bac sans qu'est
ce qu'on fait alors imaginons imaginons
on sait aujourd'hui que ce vaccin ils
empêchent les formes graves
ce qu'on ne sait pas encore c est ce qu
ils empêchent le portage du virus
ils empêchent la transmission s'ils
n'empêchent pas d'une manière très
efficace à transmission à quoi ça sert
autant je vais vous allez allez ça
l'avez vous pouvez vous pouvez vous avez
été vaccinées vous ferez deux journaux
grave mais vous pouvez quelque part le
trans pas ça c est ce que je veux dire
également dépendants mais justement il
ya des études qui sont faites là dessus
on va le savoir on va le savoir quand
aimé qu'elle mais madame on a on a mis
un an pour un vaccin canton et plusieurs
années on est en train aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit qu'ils sont efficaces en
s'aperçoit que quand on vaccine on a
quand même une diminution dans l'eee de
l'animation tout cas pour des pays comme
israël ou documents moi je suis
actionnaire on lui en première ligne les
soignants sur mon cas j'ai eu j'ai eu le
deux injections mais je ne sais pas
encore peut-être que je vais avoir un
portage du virus donc on n'a pas tant
qu'on n'a pas cette sécurité
on ne peut pas mais vous aurez des
obligations qui seront dictés par des
pays mais pas mon pays alors aidez pays
qui vous diront vous ne voyez mais vous
dirai pas si vous voulez pas vous faire
accéder vous n'irez pas non moi
j'entends beaucoup de choses et
j'entends beaucoup voient
ag voyager voyager c'est vrai que c'est
important de voyager mais la plupart des
français ils veulent pas spécialement
voyager ils veulent que le pays aurait
fonctionne pays se remette en marche
là je suis très patriote sur le coup son
coach de mu d'abord ça en vue des
grandes pensées de voyager du monde
avant d'aller au mexique avant d'aller à
droite à gauche venait aux ronces on
essaye de réouvrir nous c'est quand on
le dit le passeport moi je veux bien
l'entendre passeport mais y'aura que
nous quand on n'y a que nous qui va
avoir un passeport non dans le monde
entier ont fait un pincement monde il au
timbre il coûte 35 mal ça m'a coûté de
l'argent de faire un passeport les pays
pauvres ont un passeport aussi l'équipe
qui va financer la ville allait demander
aux touristes un retour en force et non
pas deux choses le mondial sera pas être
calculé pour non mais oui je suis pour
mais on va apprendre à vous parliez tout
à l'heure du 500 et vous disiez je sais
pas si ça va permettre la transmission
ou pas mais en fait on fait tout ça pour
éviter les formes graves on est d'accord
depuis le départ les bâtiments et berlin
donc en fait ça suffit de savoir ça nous
avons un grave épisode mais permet
surtout non et puis ce cadre est ainsi
de reprendre une vie en collectivité et
le brûlent n'attendez se tuer moi un
truc n'est pas la faute de passeport
immunitaire à la redéfinition
il est est ce que je suis content alger
pour mon voisin si j'en sais rien on
s'en fout sur le plan immunitaire que
c'est une forme grave
pardon mais on s'en fout pas sur le plan
médical sur un plan effectivement de
santé publique c'est pas le problème
l'intérêt de savoir le passeport
immunité il n'a qu'un seul intérêt
cécile m'empêche de vous savez vous
savez vous allez dire je vais aller un
tout petit peu dans votre espace sur le
passeport alors moi je fais partie des
médecins qui disent que on devrait
laisser aller les gens au cinéma avec
des jeux je pense qu'on devrait ouvrir
les lieux sportifs
quand vous avez un stade de 40000 places
en ont pour en mettre quinze mille
personnes est réparti
on pourrait le faire quand c'est en
plein air n'envoyez c'est pas moi j'ai
envie que les restaurants reprennent que
les cinémas reprennent que les théâtres
prennent que les musées roues moi j'en
ai envie mais je veux pas le passeport
pour ça je veux pas le passeport vous ça
je veux le respect des gestes barrières
je veux des jauges en particulier mais
je vais pas exiger au genre in d'être
vaccinés on va vivre
je sens que non parce qu'on va arriver à
une immunité banham c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de vous et vampires sont coriaces
j'avais entendu ce camion est donc à
vivre avec des gelées des masses toutes
lettres de jeunes attendus viendront
faire quelque chose si vous voulez c'est
un élément que je dis depuis premier
jour dans cette épidémie
mais les épidémies mois autant en
juriste j'en ai vu un certain nombre je
veux dire en tant que josé santé
publique on en a travaillé sur un
certain nombre d'épidémie est-ce que je
vous garantis c'est que j'ai dix
premiers jours ni la grippe ni la peste
il faut effectivement avoir une attitude
prudentielles et la peur mais hélas il à
l inverse de la prudence quand il ya de
la peur quelque part il ya plus de
prudence en fête premier élément
deuxième élément je vous raconte vous
signaler un point qui n'est pas
négligeable
c'est vous dire que finalement attention
quand même vous manipulez les concepts
vous on utilise des mots des mots on est
autour d'une table en parle des mots de
liberté des mots passeport pour le
juriste ça ça a des conséquences
extrêmement graves ces mots-là ces mots
que vous employez on donnera les
employés à genoux attention parce que
comme prend l'habitude de parler de nos
libertés comme ça mais c'est le jour où
il aurait plus allez demander aux
chinois allez demander aux coréens si
ces problèmes se posent pato est
effectivement nouvelle zélande
excusez moi il nous était d'aider des
leçons avec des mots que j'étais ait
fait un discours de juristes qui n'a pas
de sens mais mesure ouvrez les yeux sur
l'eau
non mentionné attendez on passe à fait
ça fait un an que tout le monde est dans
la merde dans les yeux je n'ai pas vous
laisser dire mais on ne met pas dans la
merde à cause de virus de la mère à
cause d'une politique
quant à lui répondait à m e division
alors je vous dis une chose je ne
comprends pas votre discours qui sert
certainement très juste moi je suis
approximatif et moi j'ouvre les yeux moi
je crée des six matchs par jour qui qui
qui tombe bien alors qu'ils sont
attendait m et buteur il alors elle
était axée remet tout on est fermé il ya
plus nico dossier que dire sinon ils se
sentent bien le monsieur monsieur ça je
voudrais pas que je sois tu n'arrêtes
pas ça s'appelle du cateau c'est fait
monsieur s'appelle du pathos et s'est
pas fait ça
non monsieur à manger ainsi maintenance
et du pathos mais trop tardivement mais
aucune pertinence
alors parce que si vous vous engagez sur
le terrain des airbus
est ce que c est effectivement ça mérite
un débat la presse m comme vous le
faites monde je vous rappelle
effectivement aujourd'hui j'en attendais
le attendait le cyclo monsieur on nous
avait laissé parler les gens vous avez
raison de souligner que la toxine hâtif
je me suis d'accord vous êtes
approximative totalement simplement
effectivement ce qui me dérange c'est
que vous dites je suis ok matif et
j'ouvre les yeux sans nous rendre compte
de la contradiction en soit je ne serais
pas là si tout allait mieux peut-être
que si nous les témoins approximatifs
vous pourriez ouvrir les yeux sur lui
l'homme sur une réalité monsieur c'est
que nous parlons d'un virus au taux de
létalité encore relativement faible et
sur lequel on a le droit de grève en
garde les personnes
c'est odieux de gars à ses yeux il est
alors bien ce ballon qui peut nous
éclairer la suite moi je vraiment ce que
vous dites vous avez raison parce que
nous on le vit à l'hôpital
maintenant nous on le vit à l'hôpital m
je dois vous dire quand même ce que ce
que nous vivons n'est pas que je sais je
dis quand vous avez quand vous avez 80
mille morts moi je veux pas rentrer dans
le débat il ya une tribune de monsieur
le bayer a dans le monde en le disant ça
ne compte c'est une espérance de vie non
chaque vie compte
non mais non mais laissez les deux
minutes en omettre la la je parle je
pars en tant que médecin peut-être d'un
côté le côté humaniste je rentre pas
dans le domaine juridique
il ya 80 mille morts si j'étais persuadé
si j'étais vraiment persuadé qu'on
arrivait à régler le problème avec un
passeport avec un certificat vaccinale
je vous dirais ok on y va et que s'ils
ont réglé le problème économique
je ne pense pas remis moi je pense que
effectivement pendant quelque temps on
doit vivre il faut attendre
effectivement qu'on arrive à vacciner le
maximum de population il faudra faire
attention variant il faudra voir comment
va adapter le vaccin il y aura
certainement des rappels et tout mais le
jeu il nous reste un semblant de liberté
encore et je veux pas l'altérer je ne
veux pas altéré ce semblant de liberté
et je ne pense pas que la solution si
vous voulez ce soit effectivement un
certificat parce que ça va ça va ouvrir
du jour au lendemain il ya d'autres
maladies vous l'avez dit moi je
je pense comme infectiologues à la
tuberculose à d'autres maladies si vous
mettez si on met le doigt sur met le
doigt là dedans on en surplus il n'y a
aucune il y aura aucune limite
donc il faut être patient il faut être
patient il y aura des obligations qui ne
seront dictés par les autres pays et
puis il faut il faut élargir la france
parce que malheureusement je veux dire
quand c'est une pandémie pandémie ça
veut dire que le monde entier touché et
ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens oui en
partie du monde comme ça le gêne on pond
des miss avait juste dire que plus d'un
continent est touché
c'est sympa non m c'est vrai mais qui
sera touchée il ya des gens qui j'espère
que les frontières un jour vont
fonctionner parce que il y aura une
vaccination ainsi donc vous pouvez pas
contrôler tout le monde les a si vous
voulez établir un passeport comme ça
accès à l'île faut qu'il soit quasiment
internationale alors sinon il y aura des
faux non plus de l'avant il faut être
j'essaye l'accord y est on va voir et de
faire un petit peu le jeu wii à 27%
regarder non je suis d'accord avec deux
breaks avec vous m e division non